the One Piece manga just revealed
something that will change the course of
the story like nothing has probably
since Aces battle with Blackbeard that
led to the war at Marine Forts and
that's because Ichiro order has just
kicked off a battle between Trafalgar D
water law and you guessed it Blackbeard
again a development I honestly think no
one had on their radar especially since
we just saw Marshall dth being chased
off Amazon Lily by Rayleigh and Boa
Hancock also kidnapping Luffy's Marine
friend Kobe has a little souvenir in the
process and now he has ambushed law
another one of Luffy's friends who was
on his way to the next Island after
leaving wano Blackbeard has been
obsessed with getting his hands on as
many devil fruits and as many
pornoglyphs as possible in a very very
short time we know this because while he
and Laura preparing to clash it seems
that aokiji who has teamed up with
Blackbeard 4 yet unexplained reasons has
invaded big mom's territory and has not
only taken her Pony glyph but seemingly
also kidnapped pudding one of the
selected few people in the world who can
actually decipher the road Pony glyphs
and Lead Blackbeard's to love tale
before Luffy and how should he
successfully defeat law teach has the
chance to not only add kaido's Pony
glyph on top of that but also get his
hands on Lost legendary devil fruit
powers that include the Eternal youth
surgery that doflamingo wanted above
anything else so has aokiji actually
become Luffy's enemy now is there any
chance that law could somehow win this
fight and what would it mean for Luffy
and the story overall if he loses Well
turns out we actually might know the
answer to uh all of these but first a
quick word from today's sponsor Mythic
Heroes now for me this is one of the
best Idol gotcha games out there right
now it has over 50 Heroes to collect
with a great variety of cyberpunk and
cross-dil art skins weapons and skills
to build your own team the story and
lore are surprisingly fun and I found
that the gameplay overall has been
strongly improved compared to similar
games however d by far most exciting
feature is their AFK mode because it
allows you to Auto Battle and play
hands-free with just one tap in other
words your team will simply start the
next fight automatically using the
strategy that you picked that way you
can pile up great rewards with your team
while doing something else if you
download the game now you can get 120
000 diamonds at login plus they're
giving away Amazon gift cards for 100
200 and even 300 for the top ranked
players and everyone who uses the link
in the description below will get Mythic
Heroes gift packs worth two hundred
dollars so what are you waiting for Go
download Mythic Heroes and play right
now but now back to the video to
understand why this chapter and last
battle with Blackbeard is such a big
deal we have to take a closer look at
Blackbeard's actions in the story so far
and what his overall plan is because
even though the store he tries really
hard to sell Teach as an impulsive and
dangerous idiot the truth as you well
know is that Blackbeard is one of the
most cunning characters in all of one
piece that has carefully and patiently
planned to get where he is today Luffy's
biggest rival for the title of pirate
king and right now I would say the top
Contender for reaching love tale first
as you'll remember teach who seems to be
connected to and inspired by the
legendary and Infamous pirate Roxy's
abek joined whitebeard's crew right from
the start in the hope to get his hands
on the yummy yummy Nomi according to him
the strongest devil fruit in existence
that seems to have been the core piece
in his plan to rise to the top of the
pirate worlds once he got lucky and had
the fruit in his reach instead of
stealing the fruit and getting away he
chose to murder his crewmate well
knowing that Ace would come after him I
mean his goal right from the start as we
now know was to get his hands on
whitebeard's earthquake Powers as well
which is why he joined his crew in the
first place and so his goal for this
phase of his plan was to start a war
between the Marines and Whitebeard well
knowing that he doesn't have a chance
against Whitebeard quite yet because
despite his betrayal he still fears and
respects the man so he prepares
everything for his big moment a
calculated gamble with high risk but
also immense rewards he makes sure to
get on the good side of the world
government to become a warlord and thus
gain access to the high security prison
impo town then he hands over ace to the
Marines telling them about Asus Heritage
well knowing that the government would
want to turn the execution of the pirate
King's only son into a major publicity
stunt and of course he also knows that
Whitebeard would come to save his son no
matter what because he used to be part
of that same very family that he never
really loved in the first place now once
the war had begun teach used the
commotion to enter imphal down unnoticed
and grabbed some of the most powerful
and Infamous Pirates locked away on
level 6 into his crew and so now
commanding a quite formidable Force he
grows confident enough that he will be
able to see his plan through all the way
to the end he waits until both Marines
and Pirates are exhausted from the war
and then he sees his chance swoops in
and even though he underestimated the
power of a Dying Whitebeard quite a bit
he's still able to steal the guragura
Nomi and Escape now with three essential
pieces of his plan secure in his hands
two of the most powerful devil fruits in
the world a crew of monsters and
whitebeard's vacant position amongst the
yonko and so while Luffy and the straw
hats are training during the time skip
Blackbeard starts the third phase of his
plan he knows there are still people out
there very strong people that are still
capable enough to Snuff out all of his
Ambitions and that scares him so he does
what he does best lay low and wait while
all the other yonkos are being
challenged by the members of the worst
generation Blackbeard is quite happy
securing his position and getting his
hands on as many useful and more
importantly powerful devil fruits as
possible to boost his new crew even more
I mean we've already seen that all of
his commanders have eaten some truly
frightening devil fruits and four new
ones are revealed by Oda in this chapter
as well Jesus Burgess has eaten the
rikirikinomi giving him abnormal
strength so he's easily able to lift an
entire freaking mountain.q has the shiku
shikonomi literally the sick sick fruit
which is quite ironic in a way as a
doctor he can infect people with
sickness but auger can teleport people
using the warp Ward fruit and duck use
his horse stronger has eaten the
mythical Pegasus Zone fruit basically
just gives him wings I guess because
he's already a horse but it definitely
looks like the devil fruit face of
teacher's plan is now also complete
which now brings him into the final
stage of this process that he needs to
become pirate king getting his hands on
the four Road Pony glyphs and somehow
finding a way to decipher their contents
and so for that he has laid low and
waited for the right moment he was too
scared to challenge either big mom or
kaido heads on but now that they've been
defeated by Luffy kitten law and knowing
that they would get their hands on
kaido's Pony glyph he was waiting in the
waters around wano and tracked down the
one out of the three that arguably poses
the smallest threat to him right now and
sadly that person is Law and so
Blackbeard attacks a submarine and
forces law to retreat to a nearby Island
where he can now engage him in a
one-on-one battle that he is I think a
very confident he can easily win and so
it looks like while Luffy is learning
more and more about the true nature of
devil fruits from Dr vegapunk lob who's
a doctor might well get the chance to
learn a lot more about Blackbeard's
abnormal body but even if teach is able
to defeat lawhir and get his copy of
kaido's pony glyph what about the
remaining three Well turns out he's been
on the move for the rest of them all
along we've gotten these three covers in
a row now that strongly suggests that
aokiji is in whole cake Island big mom's
territory that after her defeat is
pretty much defenseless and also where
we know another road poneglyph is hidden
in this room the first cover shows two
mysterious figures appearing in town the
second is chocolate town where Luffy
first met pudding completely frozen over
and now we see cracker one of big mom's
commanders Frozen completely stiff and
it looks exactly like this here where
aokiji throws Robin or here where he did
the same with Luffy and on top of that
brulee has realized that pudding has
vanished as well big mom's daughter of
the three-eyed tribe that allegedly at
least can naturally decipher the
inscriptions on the pony glyphs and this
of course shouts Blackbeard not only
because it's the very same chapter as
his attempt to get lost Pony glyph but
also because of this panel right here
where one of the gorosei reveals to us
that aokiji has apparently teamed up
with Blackbeard which still feels
strange because as we know from all
these moments aokiji always seemed to be
a good guy even sympathizing with Luffy
in his youth we see him here as a big
admirer of Garb and his sense for what's
truly just and fair representing a more
gentle and human side of the Marines and
the governments he protected Robin
spared Luffy on Long ring Island and
during Marine Fort and the last time we
saw him he saved his friend smoker from
being sliced into salami by doflamingo
but on the other hand it also very much
looks like he's delivering a road
poniglyph a crucial piece of information
to get Blackbeard closer to power
directly to him so what's going on here
at first glance you really have to
wonder if aokiji didn't actually just
legitimately switch sides maybe he lost
faith so much in the government after
this battle with a kainu that he decided
to tear it all down EV even if it meant
joining hands with blackbeards and to be
completely Fair it's definitely a real
possibility that I absolutely would make
for some really interesting plot down
the line here but I do think that it's
not very likely Oda has always portrayed
aokiji as a force of good on countless
occasions many of them where he didn't
need to show any kindness and he also
doesn't really seem like the type of
person who would hold a grudge or even
be out for revenge against an
organization that is full with lifelong
friends of his just look at Punk Hazard
where he went out of his way to save
smoker from being killed I don't think
that's the type of person who would want
Blackbeard out of all people to burn all
of the Marines to the grounds there are
three alternatives to kuza now having
Gone full Anakin Skywalker on us first
and in my opinion the most likely option
is that he's still with the Marines as
an undercover agent for the secret
Marine unit sword that operates
independently and more importantly
without the knowledge of the government
which also explains why the gurose
wouldn't know about about it
alternatively he could also have teamed
up with the revolutionaries a force that
wants to take down the celestial dragons
but not the Marines themselves or he
could be simply out there doing his own
thing Gathering insulin Blackbeard
independently and then delivering it to
whoever he finds the most trustworthy at
the end which would then most likely be
Luffy but honestly right now it doesn't
really matter whether kuzan is a friend
or an enemy or a spy because he is still
working with Blackbeard right now and it
looks like he will bring him not only a
second poneglyph but someone who can
translate the ancient language written
on it for teach that would have given
him two Road Pony Cliffs real quick
unless law is able to actually win this
fight somehow but is that even possible
let's look at the facts law has now a
bounty of 3 billion berries for a reason
now while he teamed up with kit to take
down big mom he is still one of the
strongest Pirates out there London only
has an incredibly versatile and Powerful
full devil fruit ability but maybe even
more importantly the brains to get the
most out of it yes Blackbeard is a real
schemer but so Islam I mean it's no
coincidence that both of them were
benefiting from the rocky Port incident
which by the way law orchestrated he can
absolutely match teach when it comes to
strategy and maneuvering and since his
devil fruit allows him teleportation as
well he could get close to Blackbeard
without giving him the chance to nullify
his powers his gamma knife attack was
one of the key points in bringing down
big mom and since he has awakened his
devil fruit now it's more powerful than
ever La also has an incredibly high
level of understanding of hockey
confirming something in this chapter
that so far we've only speculated
powerful haki allows the Nullification
of devil fruit Powers which would be a
real game changer against Blackbeard
here as well now teach on the other hand
is just ridiculously overpowered at this
point not only did he easily defeat Ace
with his Darkness fruit which power you
can see in any of those panels right
here but now wielding whitebeard's
guraguranomi he has maybe the strongest
offensive power in the world as well I
mean really just look at what Whitebeard
did to the ocean with it and on top of
that Blackbeard has dark Q with him
while lost crew still very much has to
prove their worth I mean it didn't
exactly shine all too much during the
raid on onigashima and so honestly I
think that even though law would
probably at least have a decent chance
against most people in the world at this
point I just don't see him taking down
Blackbeard I mean teach has been built
up throughout the story to be Luffy's
main rival for the one piece he's bound
to be one of the if not the main villain
of the story he just kidnapped Kobe and
was responsible for Asus capture and
Ultimate Death don't you think it would
be a little bit anti-climactic if he
could be stopped by law no offense to
law offense but you get what I'm saying
law beating teach makes absolutely no
sense neither power wise nor plot lot
wise and so I only see two options for
law to not get captured or even worse
killed by Blackbeard right here right
now and hand over his Pony glyph plus
possibly his devil fruit I think law is
very much capable enough to try and get
away from the fight and maybe even warn
Luffy and Co about his actual powers or
and I know this would be very dark but
listen it's possible he could sacrifice
himself and remotely perform the
immortality surgery on Luffy to not have
to perform it on Blackbeard now we don't
actually know what the conditions for
this ultimate ability are so it is
definitely an option I'd say because the
alternative if law actually ends up
losing this fight well that would truly
change the projective of the entire
story there's why again because it's
important law has a road poneglyph he
has one of the most valuable devil
fruits with the ability to make someone
Immortal but there is also this and you
know where the Third Road ponig live we
know right now is exactly here if
Blackbeard captures law off he will have
two Pony glyphs and a mink that could
lead him to the third one hidden in the
whale Tree on Zoe the home of the Minx
and so not only will that put blackbit
on Luffy's level with three red stones
and someone to decipher them but he
would have two of Luffy's best friends
as hostages and lavridge I mean Luffy
was so traumatized by losing Ace that he
wouldn't hesitate even a second to come
for them if he finds out that Blackbeard
might kill two of the people who are
close to him and teach is smart enough
to draw people he wants something from
out with their loved ones something we
already saw with Whitebeard and Ace so
knowing him he might just wait for Luffy
to get his hands on the fourth poneglyph
and then bait him with law and Kobe to
take it away from him and then with the
road to left tale a crew of monsters and
two or maybe even three powerful devil
fruits what really is going to stop
teach from becoming pirate king before
Luffy now where he will get the third
devil fruit and how he's able to eat
more than one devil fruit in the first
place is a whole different and story we
don't know yet but I do have a pretty
interesting theory that you can watch
right here next